>> Tucker: AT RICHARD,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'VE GOT A FOX NEWS ALERT FOR
YOU.
PRESIDENT HAS CANCELED A
SCHEDULED MEETING WITH
PRIME MINISTER OF DENMARK.
IT'S BEEN ON HIS CALENDAR FOR A
WHILE CLEAR THE REASON IS
GREENLAND.
THE PRIME MINISTER RECENTLY
DISMISSED THE IDEA OF SELLING
GREENLAND UNITED STATES PRETTY
CALLED A COMICAL, ABSURD.
SO JUST MINUTES AGO, THE
PRESIDENT READ THIS CONICAL,
OPEN MIC DENMARK IS A SPECIAL
COUNTRY WITH INVERTIBLE PEOPLE
BUT BASED ON PREP AND
PRIME MINISTER'S COMMENTS THAT
SHE WOULDN'T KNOW INTEREST IN
DISCUSSING THE PURCHASE OF
GREENLAND, I WILL BE POSTPONING
OUR MEETING SCHEDULED IN TWO
WEEKS FOR ANOTHER TIME."
THE PRIME MINISTER WAS ABLE TO
SAVE A GREAT DEAL OF EXPENSE AND
EFFORT FOR THE BOTH THE U.S. AND
DENMARK BY BEING SO DIRECT.
I THINK FOR HER THAT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO RESCHEDULING SOME
TIME AND.
"
BY THE WAY, A DEAL BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND DENMARK FOR NEW
TERRITORY WOULD NOT BE TOTALLY
UNPRECEDENTED.